wikileaks founder julian assange is in a
london courtroom this morning fighting
against a return to the u.s
more than 160 current and former world
leaders
and other lawmakers have sent the letter
to britain's prime minister
they want the extradition hearing to be
stopped and for assange not to be sent
to the u.s
where of course he faces espionage
charges over the release of secret
government documents you may recall it
was a big deal
this morning we're also learning about
children assange fathered under
extraordinary circumstances
and our elizabeth palmer spoke with
their mother a lawyer for assange
who is also now his fiancee
it's the same one is it you love that
one i tried to give them as
normal a feeling of a family as i can
and i want them to just see our love and
their father's
affection to the extent that we can
but little gabriel and max have rarely
seen their father
the revered and reviled julian assange
founder of wikileaks he's been in hiding
or as he is now
in jail since before they were born
currently he's battling extradition to
the u.s where he's charged with
conspiracy to hack a pentagon computer
and using wikileaks to publish thousands
of classified documents
my work will not be cowed assange argues
it was in the public interest
stella morris met assange a decade ago
when she joined his legal team
and then they became lovers what went
through your mind when you decided to
get pregnant with this very
controversial public figure
well he was a man i wanted to start a
family with
and i was 33 and we decided
you know let's
let's live our lives easier said than
done
for seven years assange was a fugitive
holed up in ecuador's
embassy in london as his lawyer stella
could visit
and in spite of all the scrutiny they
managed to keep their relationship
secret we found ways to be
private we had a tent in his room that
we put
you know fairy lights in and a tent a
tent
yeah we had a um yeah like a camping
tent
was that so even if there were cameras
they wouldn't be able to see
right yes then last year assange was
dragged out of the embassy and jailed
while a judge considers the extradition
why should julian not be extradited
to the u.s there's no way julian will
face a fair trial in the u.s
going public now when assange could be
looking at decades of u.s
prison time is a calculated emotional
appeal to the british
court so are you hoping that
the sight of your two beautiful children
and the news that he's got a loving
stable relationship
will factor in his not being extradited
well i think the court has to deal with
the reality that he has a family
in the uk he also has a history
former colleagues who call him a liar
and an egomaniac
and allegations that he colluded with
russian meddling in the 2016 u.s
election something he denies
what do you tell the kids about daddy i
tell them that julian is a hero
and they speak to him every day whatever
the courts decide
stella morris stands by her man
for cbs this morning i'm elizabeth
palmer in london
a lot more happening in the ecuadorian
embassy in london yeah
quite the family resemblance there as
well exactly no the kids call it ride or
die she's definitely ride or die for
julian assange
he has somebody he can count on for the
other side of julian exactly
all right i thank you liz palmer